hello and welcome to another 3abn today
Bible q a my name is Ricky Carter and
I'm going to be your host today we've
got some answers for you that you have
sent in your questions and we've got
this illustrious panel who's going to
give you the answers from God's word
that's where we need to get them from
from God's word
and I want to introduce you to our panel
here to my right I have brother denzy
brother John denzi welcome to the
program brother thank you so much it's a
blessing again to participate in 3abn
Bible q a amen amen and next time we
have sister Shelly
I just want to thank everybody that
sends in these wonderful questions we're
having fun answering them amen welcome
sister and next to her we have brother
Daniel Perrin yes thank you very much
glad to be here and like you said always
good questions and I love to see where
they lead us in God's word amen amen
well before we get into the word of God
we need to ask for the holy spirit to
guide us to help us to understand what
his word says so brother Daniel could
you share with us a word of prayer yes
please
our loving Heavenly Father we would be
adrift in this world if it were not for
your word and your holy spirit to guide
us and so we ask right now as we come to
your word not with our own wisdom not
with our own strength with the wisdom
and strength that comes from you lead us
and guide us as we speak and God we know
that there are people watching and
listening who will be ministered to
right now may these words uh from your
word be administrated them we pray in
Jesus name amen amen amen well before we
get into our program I want to let the
viewers at home know how they can
participate you can participate one of
three ways you can email us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv or
for those of you who would like to text
us you can text us at
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 and then for those of you
who want in Instagram you can send us
your questions that way as well at 3abn
underscore official that's 3abn
underscore official
all right well let's get into our
program
president yes sir I've got a question
for you you get the first one here we go
why do the prayers of many Christians go
unanswered I've been wrestling with my
faith and trust in Jesus even when the
Bible says whatever you ask in Jesus
name you will receive
it's because the language used wasn't
right
how am I able to trust God even when he
doesn't make sense that's from sheko who
emailed that to us
thank you shekel
um it's a it's a question that somehow
confuses people because
sometimes they don't see the answer come
in the time that they are expecting it
I'm glad you said that some
some Christians do not see answer to
their prayers surely you have seen some
answers to your prayers and I'd like to
say that some prayers God will answer
right away you know you ask give us this
day our daily bread God answers that
right away uh and when you when you go
to the Lord in sincerity of heart and
ask for forgiveness of sin God answers
that right away and many others uh got
answers right away but there are some
things that we ask that depend on things
sometimes if you're praying for someone
God has to do a work of working in the
heart of the individual and that person
has to be convinced of their own choice
of their own free will to move in the
direction for example if you're praying
for a loved one to to return to the Lord
God is not going to force the person to
return to the Lord he will influence the
person through the Holy Spirit and
through uh circumstances circumstances
and situations but the person has to
make their own decisions
you know you you mentioned is it because
of the language it wasn't right no you
see God looks beyond our language and
looks at the heart looks at the heart
and if we if we look at the scriptures
that Matthew 21 verse 21 and 22 notice
the words here so Jesus answered and
said to them surely I say to you if you
have faith and do not doubt there is a
key if you have faith and do not doubt
you will not only do what is done to the
Fig Tree but also if you say to this
mountain be removed and cast into the
sea it will be done and whatever things
you ask believing you will receive and
this is the part where some people they
let go too soon and they say well God is
not going to answer my prayer so we need
to continue praying and he says pray and
it says ask and it's really ask and
continue asking because God is more
willing than Earthly parents are or even
the person that loves you the more to
give you the good things that you ask
for amen but there is the factor of
believing and having faith in the Lord
and the Lord is so good so wonderful
that he doesn't answer every prayer in
the way we're asking because sometimes
we may be asking for something that may
not be good for us or may not be good
for us right now but it may be good for
us later
so James chapter 1 verse 5 through 7
says if any of you lacks wisdom let him
ask of God who gives to all liberally
and without reproach and it will be
given to him but let him ask in faith
with no doubting for He Who doubts is
like a wave of the sea driven and tossed
by the wind so I encourage you to
continue trusting in the Lord look at
what the Lord has done for you in the
past and know that he loves you and
wants the best for you
in Jeremiah chapter 29 verse 11 it says
for I know the thoughts that I think
toward you says the Lord thoughts of
peace and not of evil to give you a
future and a hope and this is something
to keep in mind that God loves us wants
the best for us and in the time that is
his best he will answer but sometimes
the answer is no because that is the
best for us yes exactly amen thank you
brother
all right sister Shelley I have your
first question okay
how did Abel know to sacrifice fat
portions from the firstborn of the flock
that's from Gary in Washington state and
he emailed that to us okay Gary Genesis
4 4. let's go ahead and read that it
says Abel also brought her the firstborn
of his flock and of their fat and the
Lord respected Abel in his offering
that's Genesis chapter four you may not
realize this but the first 11 chapters
of Genesis are merely a highlight reel
of 2 000 years of God's interactions
with people so in the first 11 chapters
we've got the creation we've got the
fall we've got the flood we've got the
dispersion and it doesn't give all of
the details so what happened when sin
penetrated God's Spear of influence and
Adam and Eve sinned sin penetrated their
heart they lost their spiritual
virginity there was nothing that humans
could do Isaiah 64 6 says that all of
our righteous acts are like filthy rags
before him so God came in and in Genesis
3 15 he introduces the Everlasting
Covenant and says there's this seed who
is coming he promises this deliverer and
then he introduced the substitutionary
sacrificial system now we don't see in
these first 11 chapters of 2 000 years
of History we don't see where God taught
them but obviously God taught Adam and
Eve the truth of this and they taught
their sons now the reason when God
introduced the sacrificial system this
opened the pathway to righteousness by
faith for these early ancient people and
we know that because we know there's no
way to regain our righteousness yet
we've got Abel Enid Noah job all of
these men are righteous so when we look
at what Abel did it says in 11 Hebrews
11 and verse 4 by faith Abel offered to
God a more excellent sacrifice than Cain
through which he obtained witness that
he was righteous and even Jesus by his
own testimony Jesus talked about in
Matthew 23 35
the blood of righteous Abel so we don't
have all the details recorded two
thousand years of history in 11 chapters
but we know that God taught them and
that we see it all through Genesis that
there was a substitutionary sacrificial
system amen thank you sister Shelley
all right brother Daniel have your first
question and this is your opportunity
for a four-minute answer you ready okay
are we Sinners by nature or by choice
and that was emailed to us all right a
short question but we could answer that
quickly or in a long version I'll give
you the medium version here maybe you've
heard somebody say uh I couldn't help it
or it's just the way I am or I really
didn't have a choice especially when it
deals with temptation and sin and maybe
it was you who said that and is that
true do we have a choice
for Lucifer he was sinless until he made
a choice Isaiah 28 15 and 16. it says
you were perfect in your ways from the
day you were created till iniquity was
found in You by the abundance of your
trading you became filled with violence
within and you sinned and so sin arises
by the exercise of Free Will which God
had given and by a choice
um that was in heaven though what about
here on Earth well Adam and Eve also as
we know created sinless until they made
a choice Romans 5 verse 12 therefore
just as through one man that's through
his choice sin entered the world and
death through sin and thus death spread
to all men because all sinned again we
have a choice being made by each person
of an active Choice all right so Adam
then blamed Eve and Eve blamed the
serpent but it really doesn't matter who
you're pointing the finger at you cannot
Free Yourself of the consequence that
you are responsible for the choice that
you made that was then though what about
now what do I inherit what is my
spiritual genealogy that leads all the
way back to Adam and what we inherit is
we inherit the physical and mental and
spiritual weakness inside and outside
among other things that makes it
impossible for us to resist temptation
without the aid of the Holy Spirit
dwelling with in us the Bible if it's
nothing else is simply an invitation to
you and to me to make a choice listen to
these verses Isaiah 7 verse 15. for
before the child shall know to refuse
the evil and choose the good we
recognize that each child comes to an
age in which they have a choice to make
about what they know is true First John
3 verse 4 whoever commits sin also
commits lawlessness and sin is
lawlessness that's a choice to reject or
go against God's law
James 4 verse 17 therefore to him who
knows to do good and does not do it to
him it is sin in Ezekiel 18 verse 20 the
soul whose sins shall die the son shall
not bear the guilt of the father nor the
father bear the guilt of the son think
of the example of David here he had
weaknesses but it wasn't until he acted
upon them and those actions began with
his thoughts that it became sin when he
saw another man's wife from the rooftop
he had a choice that's why the Bible has
phrases like this abstain from every
form of evil resist the devil and he
will flee from you flee sexual
immorality abhor what is evil cling to
what is good do not give place to the
devil uh by analogy I have I am born
with a nature to eat I have the desire
to eat in this case it's a god-given
desire that we have damaged through sin
but I do not become an eater until I
choose unless I choose to put food in my
mouth Temptation and our inherited
weakness is not sin and the reason this
question matters is that Jesus came to
Earth and became like us to be made like
his brother in Hebrews too but he did
not become a sinner he resisted sin he
had a choice to sin and he faced it just
like me with the same weaknesses of body
and that I have so how did he do it Luke
2 40 wonderful text here gives us an
indication says and the child grew and
became strong in spirit filled with
wisdom and the grace of God was on him
Jesus had not sinned he did not need the
grace of God that provides pardon and
mercy for sin but he received from God
the grace that gives power to resist
temptation and be victorious over sin
and guess what that same Grace is
available to you and me Amen brother
amen thank you very much
all right brother Lindsay here's your
second question
why did God put the serpent in the
garden to begin with that's from Sandra
in North Dakota and she texted that to
us
I understand your question
in Genesis chapter 1 verse 31
uh the Lord looking at everything he had
made it says then God saw everything
that he had made and indeed it was very
good so the evening and the morning were
the sixth day when we talk about the
serpent the way God created the serpent
it was a beautiful animal one of the
most beautiful animals that God created
but the serpent was used as a medium
Satan used to serpent as a medium so if
you mean that why did God allow the
serpent the devil to go into the Garden
of Eden then that's a question that we
can consider in the context of the great
controversy between good and evil that
is that Satan created a rebellion in
heaven and then was looking for
opportunities to to deceive as many as
possible came to this earth and
presented to Eve first the temptation to
eat of the Forbidden tree the tree of
knowledge of Good and Evil so the
Temptation was presented to Eve
evaluated the Temptation and the way it
was presented hey you are going to be as
God knowing good and evil painted the
eating of the fruit as of something of
benefit you will be as God knowing good
and evil as if knowing good and evil as
well was a benefit they did not need to
know evil it was a choice as you already
heard uh a moment ago
Eve made a choice to sin by partaking of
the Forbidden tree and eating of the
Forbidden tree and Adam joined Eve in
that choice so this is why we are in the
controversy a war between good and evil
we have choices to make so again the
serpent that God made was a beautiful
animal there was nothing wrong with it
was made very good but Satan used a
serpent chose that one perhaps because
it was one of the most beautiful animals
and the fact that the serpent uh
received that from now on you're gonna
drag yourself along the ground means
that it was not the way it moved before
so we have here this situation we are
involved in a great controversy between
good and evil every person has a choice
and we can all choose to follow Jesus
and if we choose to follow Jesus there
await for us
everlasting life where there is no pain
sorrow sickness nor suffering of any
kind and there will be no devil to tempt
us so
um I hope you consider the possibility
of allowing Jesus to come into your life
and living a life that you know will
bring you the joy and peace that God
offers and not only that in the world to
come no suffering and no pain no
sickness nor death amen I'm looking
forward to that day
all right sister Shelley I have your
second question okay
what does the Bible say about the
composition of the Trinity while Jesus
was on Earth
did the godhead consist only of the
father and the Holy Spirit for that
duration that's from Cecilia who emailed
that to us
because it shows you are a thinking
Christian you're trying to understand
the word of God in Malachi 3 6 God says
I am the Lord I change not amen now the
word Trinity is a word that a label that
Scholars use
to Define our three in one God the the
word that the scripture actually uses is
godhead but the scripture clearly
shows there is God the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit
in fact there's 58 triadic passages that
talk about the three persons of the
godhead they're the same in the purpose
plan and in their qualities are the same
and for those of you at home who say I
am how you can say Father and Son and
Holy Spirit of one God
the equation we need to use it's not one
plus one plus one it's one times one
times one
that equals one
so the interesting thing about
understanding the godhead is when the
second person of the godhead
stepped out of heaven and came down to
take on our flesh Paul says in
Colossians 2 9
in him dwells all the fullness of the
godhead bodily in the person of Jesus
Christ how can that be
1 divided by one is one the composition
of the godhead did not change the second
person of the godhead not second in
Authority not he was just second in the
full Revelation when he took on our
flesh we still had Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit one of them was just
embodied in flesh he walked for 40 days
with the disciples acts 1 he ascended in
that same flesh well not quite the same
it was glorified in Hebrews 13 8 says
that Jesus Christ is the same yesterday
today and forever so that same person
Jesus Christ in whom the fullness of the
body God had dwelt bodily is now in
heaven at the right hand of the father
on the throne interceding on our behalf
he is our high priest and he invites you
to come boldly to the throne amen of God
because he can save to the uttermost
amen amen
all right brother Daniel I have your
second question a little bit long but
here we go
can you please help me understand
Proverbs 22 6.
as a mother it cuts my heart to know
that a child who we raised and exposed
to Jesus ways is now acting up literally
in this world and of this world
we feel as parents that we did not do
our part in raising her to love Jesus
the most and be wise
how can we reconcile this promise when
they reach their teen years and a child
started to depart from his ways that's
from Ruth in the Philippines and she
emailed that to us okay
thank you Ruth and I can hear in your
question a mother's heart who continues
in daily prayer for your daughter I know
many parents the world over are in a
similar experience and each one of us
Longs for our children to be walking in
the truth but I think about God the
Father Who experienced the same loss you
think about the rebellion in heaven
among the Angels who God created and
among his children here on Earth Adam
and Eve and the rest of us and I listen
to Jesus words in Matthew 23 37 how
often I wanted to gather your children
together as a hen gathers her chicks
under her wings but you were not willing
so God knows what you're going through
and has wisdom and strength for you
through this Proverbs 22 verse 6 says
train up a child in the way he should go
and when he's old he will not depart
from it we cannot this this is not a
promise it says that you can somehow
manipulate circumstances to force your
children into a path that you choose for
them God gives free will to each of his
children including yourself and we
cannot somehow through correct parenting
actions Force our children into what we
would like them to do so how are we to
understand this a proverb is a general
truth from God's word that we apply to
the specifics of our life and while a
proverb is true there are other factors
also that influence things for example
if you work hard you will reap and enjoy
the rewards of your labor and that's
generally true in their Bible Proverbs
that say that sort of thing but there
are other factors a big storm hits your
partner runs away with the money
you know there's an accident something
like that and so with all God's promises
they are conditional based upon human
choices and that is the other factor
that is involved in this promise there
are other choices going on
and so we try to see this statement
Through The Eyes of a father or a mother
in ancient Israel their teens didn't go
away to college and choose the career
path they really followed in the
footsteps that were laid out by parents
for them and this is what that text is
dealing with when you when you uh
through your life illustrate the path
that you are walking on it sets an
example for your kids and that's the
general truth here this proverb really
invites you to let God lead you to
understand what his will is for your
kids and train up your children in that
path he has for them so what shall we
understand this proverb to mean
parenting is important it is influential
and what you do as a parent matters that
Hebrew word train there it only appears
five times that Hebrew word in the Bible
and it deals with inaugurating or uh
dedicating something which tells you
that the very first steps of parenting
are really significant even though you
may not see the fruit of it then and you
may not see the fruit of it now don't
waste your influence and don't stop
praying I can tell you that here in the
Pastoral Department I talk and pray with
parents and I have a list of names of
parents and kids who I pray for who I've
talked with mothers and fathers saying
please pray for my daughter pray for my
son and I want you to know that there
are people lifting up their voices in
prayer for your kids and we're not going
to stop doing that amen thank you
brother Daniel
well brother Dinsey before I give you
your third question I want to remind our
viewers at home how they can participate
you can participate again one of three
ways you can email us at bibleqa at
3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv or
you can text us to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 and for those of you who
are on Instagram you can send us your
questions to at 3abn underscore official
that's 3abn underscore official
all right brother John here's your third
question okay
can sin infect God's people again in the
new perfect world to come that's from
Krish in Canada she texted that to us
thank you Krish
um the answer to the question you
mentioned the perfect world uh the
answer is no there are some scriptures
that help us understand that and I'd
like to read some of them for you
Revelation chapter 21 is where I began
in verse one now I saw a new Heaven and
a new Earth for the first Heaven and the
first Earth had passed away also there
was no more sea then I John saw the holy
city New Jerusalem coming down out of
Heaven from God prepared as a bride
adorned for her husband and I heard a
loud voice from Heaven saying behold the
Tabernacle of God is with men and he
will dwell with them and they shall be
his people God himself will be with them
and be their God and notice God will
wipe away every tear from their eyes
there shall be no more death nor sorrow
nor crying there shall be no more pain
for the former things have passed away
and so sin is gone sin has caused death
sorrow crying diseases pain mean of
every kind and these things will be done
away with in the book of Nahum chapter 1
verse 9 the Bible says why do you
conspire against the Lord he will make
an utter end of it Affliction will not
arise will not rise up a second time we
are in a great controversy between good
and evil but God will make an utter end
of it there will be no more evil and so
because of this is a once done once over
a battle between good and evil amen God
has revealed to us that God's people win
and so Ephesians chapter 1 verse 17 and
through 19 says these words which I like
for you to consider that the god of our
Lord Jesus Christ the father of Glory
may give you the spirit of wisdom and
Revelation in the knowledge of him the
eyes of your understanding being
enlightened that you may know what is
the hope of his calling what are the
riches of the glory of his inheritance
in the Saints and what is the exceeding
greatness of his power toward us who
believe according to the power working
of his mighty power the eyes of our
understanding being enlightened we will
understand
the great content between good and evil
and how much uh damage and pain and
suffering evil has caused and no one
will desire to ever sin again when we
look at what God has done his Mercy how
much he has endured how long he had his
hand how stretched offering Mercy to
Sinners and they refused and how much
evil was done and when we look at the
scars in the hands of Jesus Christ that
will forever be a reminder of the great
controversy between good and evil we
will not desire to sin we will know that
he loves us and that anything apart from
being within God's law and God's will is
is only suffering that has already we've
gone through that and nobody will desire
ever to do that again amen amen thank
you brother
all right sister Shelley I have your
third question okay
who was Melchizedek and what is the
order of Melchizedek
how was Melchizedek related to Jesus
that's from Moses in Namibia and he
emailed that to us okay Moses you know
Melchizedek is mysterious figure he is
introduced in Genesis 14 when Abraham is
returning he is just routed some
marauding kings that had taken off lot
and he runs until to Melchizedek
mckisseldick was the king of Salem but
he also held the position of priest of
the most high god did you know that
Melchizedek is the only person in the
entire Bible the only human until Jesus
Christ who held both positions as king
and high priest the levitical order the
priests and the Kings Kings weren't
allowed to be priests priests weren't
allowed to be Kings so this is what's
interesting
uh Abraham meets him he tithes gives him
a tenth of all of his War booty and we
don't see Melchizedek mentioned again
until the history is repeated in Hebrews
in the New Testament
so there is a verse in Hebrews 7 verse
3.
that translators rendered the original
Greek to say that Melchizedek was
without father without mother without
genealogy having neither beginning of
days nor the end of life
the intention of the original Greek is
much better understood in the ancient
pashetta this is the Syriac Bible and
the way they render it is whose father
and mother
are not written in the genealogies see
it didn't make any it was important to a
little biblical priest that he could
prove what his genealogy is because you
had to be a levite it didn't matter for
Melchizedek he was both King and priest
and he was a human he had a mother and
father
and what we see is that Christ comes
along he is the only other person
in the Bible to hold both King and high
priest and Hebrews 5 6 says that Christ
was in the order of Melchizedek as
opposed to the levitical order he was in
the likeness of melchizedeks as king and
high priest
here's the bottom line
Melchizedek was not Jesus Christ
if Melchizedek had been without
beginning and end he would be God
himself and there would have been no
other reason for another appearance of
the uh another priest to arise so Christ
is not a successor of Melchizedek but
Christ's priesthood was similar to his
amen thank you sister Shelley
all right brother Daniel have your third
question here we go
what do you say to people who tell you
that your mom is watching over you from
heaven
that's from Beth in Florida and she
texted that question okay thank you Beth
for sharing that question and this is a
practical question that I think many of
us may have opportunity to face and it
provides an opportunity of witness as
well so I think it really depends on who
it is who says this to you and the
manner in which they say it if somebody
knows you maybe it's a family or a
friend and they know what you believe
and they're trying to maybe push you or
prove something or frustrate you and I
assume there can be people like that the
occasion might be right to Simply leave
it alone and say nothing but that's a
lot different from a co-worker who is
really genuinely trying to offer
condolences and genuine kindness and so
we need to have the discernment the
wisdom from God to know what to say and
when to say it at the right time and
really be open to the prompting of the
Holy Spirit and I think about Matthew 13
where Jesus expresses the same truth
twice in different ways he tells the
parable of the sower and just tells the
story to the crowd but among his
disciples he begins to explain it and
piece by piece what it means listen here
to Colossians chapter 4 verse two to six
I think this is a great text to address
this where Paul says pray also for us
that God would open open to us a door
for the word to speak the mystery of
Christ for which I'm also in chains that
I'm may make it manifest as I ought to
speak walk in wisdom toward those who
are outside I think that phrase there is
useful Redeeming the time let your
speech always be with Grace seasoned
with salt that you may know how you
ought to answer each one and so we pray
Lord give me the right words at the
right time for this certain individual
so a couple of principles here number
one is to say only what is true in other
words do your best to be careful not to
agree with things that you do not agree
with just because you're an agreeable
and nice person
number two and whatever you say be kind
uh if it is a stranger or an
acquaintance it might be the best
response just to say thank you I
appreciate your kindness and leave it at
that there's nothing untrue when you say
that but even when we do share truth
from God's word we want it to come out
of kindness we want to speak the truth
in love we don't necessarily want to hit
people with Bible texts we want to be
ready to give an answer for what we
believe but in meekness and fear as
Peter says in chapter 3 15. that means
without being pushy or demanding and
next we want to be wise to follow God's
timing and let him open doors for us
maybe God might lead you to come back to
somebody and return to them and say
something like remember when you told me
my mom was watching over me I really
appreciated your thoughtfulness and I
could tell that you trust the promises
of God's word and I want to share with
you what I've learned from God's word
you also might prepare a few responses
to Simply say what you believe in
response I'm looking forward to seeing
my mother again when Jesus comes and
raises her to life or I'm grateful and
happy for the hope of the Resurrection
or you could simply say I have a
favorite Bible verse that talks about
that and share first Thessalonians 4 16
the Lord himself will descend from
heaven with a shout with the voice of
the Archangel and the Trump of God and
the dead in Christ shall rise first amen
anyway in your own situation and in the
moment let God lead you and what you say
will have an impact on people amen amen
thank you brother Daniel
all right brother Dinsey I've got your
fourth and final question and this is
your opportunity to give us a four
minute answer
according to John chapter 5 verse 24
I have everlasting life with Jesus
but I have strongholds I cannot overcome
I am a sinner I live day after day in
constant turmoil that I am not good
enough please reiterate more on this
verse as I'm about to just say forget it
and give up
I understand conditions for sins but I
can't live every day wondering if I'm
going to make it or not that's from
Cheryl in Illinois
Cheryl I think we hear an echo of your
experience in many many other people
that are with us in this program
and I'd like to first talk about this
part that says I live day after day and
in constant turmoil and that I am not
good enough the good news is that Jesus
is good enough amen and it is because of
his life and what he did for you on the
cross that you can have everlasting life
in Romans chapter 3 verse 24 we have the
following words being justified freely
by his grace through the Redemption that
is in Christ Jesus we have redemption in
Christ Jesus
you say you have strongholds to overcome
then we must put all these things in the
hands of the Lord Jesus Christ in
Ephesians chapter 2 verse 8 through 10
we have the following words and I think
you know this verse for by Grace you
have been saved through faith and that
not of yourselves it is the gift of God
not of Works lest anyone should boast
for we are his workmanship created in
Christ Jesus for good works which God
hath has prepared beforehand that we
should walk in them so yes by the grace
of the Lord you can live a life trusting
in Him and it is true what you said I
have strongholds I cannot overcome I am
a sinner you are right you cannot
overcome those on your own this is why
we have a powerful Savior and he knows
that we cannot overcome on our own this
is why he gives us all the help that we
need to be Overcomers and so it's a it's
a learning experience Jesus says if
anyone uh Wills to come after me let him
take up his cross daily and and follow
me so daily we must take up our cross
and follow Jesus well what is the cross
for or to crucify self those strongholds
those desire to sin are going to be
there however as you focus on Jesus as
you walk with him day by day those
desires will become less and less and
your desire to be faithful will grow and
grow amen and I'd like to point to you
to Colossians chapter 1 verse 27 to whom
God will to make known what are the
richest of the glory of this mystery
among the Gentiles which is Christ in
you the hope of glory amen Christ in you
is the hope of glory every day we follow
Jesus we let him come into our hearts
and Christ in US is the hope of glory
what happens when Christ is in us we
learn from the Apostle Paul in
Philippians chapter 4 verse 13 I can do
all things through Christ so those
strongholds uh are going to lose their
power as day by day you walk with Jesus
amen uh trusting in Him trusting in that
he's doing a work that you cannot do we
cooperate with him in the process of
overcoming Temptation will come
and we're not to look at the Temptation
and say I can't handle the Temptation
it's just too strong for me we focus on
Jesus amen and when we focus on Jesus
because he was tempted in all points
like as we are we depend on his strength
to overcome that's why we have in
Philippians chapter 1 verse 6 being
confident of this very thing that he who
has begun a good work in you will
complete it until the day of Jesus
Christ day by day we cooperate with
Jesus day by day we learn to be
victorious in first John chapter 2 verse
it says my little children these things
I write unto you that if any man sin we
have an advocate with the father Jesus
Christ he will not leave you alone for a
moment Jesus is ever present to give you
the victory but choices must be made on
the side of Jesus because uh when we
choose Jesus
we are more than conquerors through his
power amen amen thank you brother John
all right sister Shelly I have your
fourth and final question and here's
your opportunity to give us a
four-minute answer
yeah
I'm involved in Bible study with some
people who are not of the Adventist
Faith these people classify Jesus as
just a prophet my question is was Jesus
mission on Earth to prophesy or to
fulfill prophecy or both that's from
James in Wisconsin and he texted that to
us oh James I hope you have a pin in a
paper because this is so critical there
are so many people who don't understand
the identity of Jesus Christ the Bible
the Old Testament records four thousand
years of God's interactions with
Humanity the New Testament about a
hundred years but what we see in the Old
Testament what is the unifying theme
from Genesis to Revelation is that our
God is a covenant making Covenant
keeping God and the Old Testament is
really all about the coming Messiah the
New Testament it's about the arrival of
Christ they both mean the same thing
Messiah Christ they mean the anointed
one so we see him introduced in Genesis
3 15 and in the Old Testament there are
125 Prophecies of Jesus now I want to
read this to you Dr Peter Stoner who was
a former chairman of the Department of
Mathematics astronomy and Engineering at
Pasadena College in California he with
his class he gave his class just eight
of those 125 prophecies that the Old
Testament talks about Jesus and and he
had his students
apply the principle of probability guess
what the odds that one man could even
fulfill just eight of those prophecies
was a trillion times a trillion times a
billion to one wow that is one followed
by 33 zeros in other words it couldn't
just happen amen Jesus is not an
imposter and what the New Testament
tells us write these scriptures down
Philippians 2 5-8 says that Jesus was
God that he is God that it is God who
came down and humiliated himself to take
on the form of man and he humbled
himself and became obedient even to the
point of the death on a cross you know
in John chapter 1 verses one through
three it says in the beginning was the
word the word was with God the Word was
God nothing was made that wasn't made
through him the word became flesh and
dwelt among us so that is Jesus Christ
he is God he is much more than a prophet
Isaiah 9 verses 6 and 7 says to us unto
us a child is born and a son is given he
the government will be upon his
shoulders He Shall be Called wonderful
counselor Mighty God
Everlasting father and Prince of Peace
Micah 5 2 says but you Bethlehem through
though you are little among the
thousands of Judah yet out of you shall
come forth to me the one to be ruler of
Israel whose goings forth are from old
from Everlasting so here's the bottom
line
before God created the Earth Revelation
13 8 tells us he had a Salvation plan of
righteousness by faith and Jesus Christ
is the Lamb who was slain before the
foundation of the Earth the Bible tells
us in Hebrews 13 20 his blood is the
blood of the Everlasting Covenant the
blood of the Covenant of righteousness
by faith second Corinthians 5 21 says he
was made to be sin who knew no sin so
that we could become the righteousness
of God in Christ Jesus there's nothing
we can do to make ourselves righteous we
receive Christ as our savior he
justifies Us by it makes us righteous by
faith not guilty but he also the second
aspect of Salvation is he works in us to
sanctify us he works in us to Will and
to do the good pleasure he is so mighty
God he loves you so much that he died on
calvary's Cross for you amen amen thank
you sister
all right brother Daniel
I've got your fourth and final question
are you ready I'm ready all right here
we go
will there be meat eaters in heaven
please give me scripture that's from Pat
in Oregon and she texted that question
to us all right thank you Pat and I want
the same thing you want I want scripture
and I'll get to the bottom line first
there will be former meat eaters in
heaven and let me show you why uh the
diet and God intended for humans to eat
his plan was in Genesis 1 29 I've given
you every herb that yields seed which is
on the face of all the Earth and every
tree whose fruit yields seed to you it
shall be for food the diet humans were
designed to run on in a sinful World
included plants but it did not include
animals and if sin had not been chosen
that would not have changed but what
about man's relationship to the animals
and we see that God gave adam the task
of naming the animals and so he was
familiar with each one of them that's in
Genesis 2 19 and in Genesis 1 26 he was
given authority to care for them and
that's not a domination but one of
responsible care so our diet was one of
uh plants and we were to care for the
animals meat was not permitted until
after the flood because of sin Genesis 9
verse 3 says every moving thing that
lives shall be food for you I've given
you all these things even as the green
herbs but you shall not eat flesh with
its life that is the blood and so even
the meat that was permitted was to be
drained of blood removing the components
that usually provide flavor and moisture
in other words making the meat less
desirable and less tasty meat became a
survival necessity for those for whom
there was nothing better available
because remember Before the Flood food
grew in abundance and the degradation of
the Botanical World probably kept pace
with the decreasing life spans and so
there was abundant food before the flood
but after the flood the landscape was
pretty Barren and there was nothing yet
to eat and so in God's plan even when
meat was permitted it was to be
undesirable to them
in God's Heavenly Kingdom which is
perfect and sinless and on the earth
made new what will we eat then will it
be the diet that is before sin
established by God or the diet that was
permitted after and as a result of sin
we know that In Heaven There Will Be the
tree of life that Adam ate from we find
that referenced in Revelation 2 verse 7
and 22 verse 14 and along with it there
is the invitation to eat of the tree of
life and I intend on receiving and
accepting that invitation
eternal life is restored which means
that our bodies are operating as they
were intended to operate share with you
a couple of other texts Revelation 21
verse 5 where God says behold I make all
things new this means that they are
brand new that they are renewed it's not
something different it's not a different
plan but it is the same new plan made
new revelation 22 verse 3 says and there
shall be no more curse all the curse of
sin is gone and Isaiah 11 verse 9
speaking of the new Earth uh Isaiah says
they shall not hurt or destroy in all my
Holy Mountain and so that indicates to
me that when we arrive in heaven and on
the new Earth we will be living
according to the plan that God intended
originally so will there be meat eaters
in heaven yes there will be former meat
eaters whose greatest desire will be to
satisfy themselves with the good things
that God promised in Psalm 103 verse 5
listen to this he satisfies your mouth
with good things so that your youth is
renewed like the eagles
that's good amen thank you brother that
was very good you know it's wonderful to
get together with my brothers and
sisters here to study God's word it's
just like a family and we can get
together and see what God's word says do
you have family and friends where you
can study the word of God together I
encourage you to do so you know you
could even if someone is not there right
there at your home you can call them on
the phone
do a Bible study with them on the phone
maybe if you've got a video phone or if
you have your smartphone you could do a
video chat Skype them have a group Bible
study it's fabulous to get together and
study God's word
well we're just about to run out of time
but before we do I just want to let you
know that on the screen that's coming up
next you're going to see some
information that I want to remind you
how you can participate with 3bm today
Bible q a you're going to have some
information there you'll see and but
don't go away we'll be right back
if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3ab in Bible q a for answers from
God's word
welcome back well our time is almost up
but before we go let's get some final
thoughts from our panel
brother denzy can you share some final
thoughts yes uh Cheryl you know you talk
about strongholds uh 3abn a fall camp
meeting overcoming through Christ of
many sermons on overcoming through
Christ we encourage you to go to YouTube
and look for the 3bn fall camp meeting
2022 or call 3avn to find out more but
we encourage you to continue trusting
the Lord and realize that like Paul we
can do all things and be victorious amen
and I just want to say that
God
nobody is worthless to God you are worth
nothing less than the price that he paid
for you to redeem you when when God came
down to become a human and be our
substitute to pay our sin penalty none
of us can live Cheryl don't you think
for one second that your struggle isn't
one that we would all have and do have
from time to time we've just got to say
oh Lord fill me with your Holy Spirit
lead me and guide me he loves you so
much amen amen
I loved Harry and Shelley talk about
Jesus and I just want to reiterate what
she said I hope you had a pen handy
because it's easy to listen to people
talk about the scriptures but then to go
and look those things up and say Lord
leave me I heard I think like 15 or 20
different scriptures there that you used
and it reminds me of what Jesus said
there I think it's in John 5 39 said you
search the scriptures because you think
that in these you have life but they
point to me and so we look through the
Old Testament especially and it's easy
to say I don't understand what this
means I challenge you to say this this
text talks about Jesus and I'm gonna
find him in there and it's going to be
worth it and you know from start to
finish there in Genesis 1 1 and I know
you'll find Jesus there and we know we
certainly find him in the Book of
Revelation but amen amen amen thank you
everyone well I want to encourage you to
continue your love for God I want to
share that with this little scripture
song you shall love the Lord out with
all your heart with all your soul and
with all your strength Deuteronomy 6
verse 5
Deuteronomy six for five God bless
that's cute
[Music]
foreign